hello welcome to khan academy ed talks i
am caroline who flexer the ceo and
co-founder of khan academy kids which is
a mobile app for children's two through
eight that's focused on literacy
math and social emotional learning
today we are celebrating national
reading month and i am excited to talk
with our special guest christy yamaguchi
who is a olympic gold medalist author
and philanthropist
if you have questions for christy please
drop them into the chat and before we
get started i want to remind you that
khan academy is a non-profit
organization we're able to do the work
that we do thanks to the generosity and
donations from folks like all of you so
if you're able to give please go to khan
academy.org
slash donate
and you'll find a place where you can
make that donation and we are so
grateful for anything that you can give
to our mission
i also wanted to recognize the
organizations that have helped support
our work during the pandemic including a
t
general motors and fastly
finally if you want to listen to this
podcast again or find previous
broadcasts you can find them at homeroom
with sal the podcast anywhere you get
your podcasts
so let's get started today i'm thrilled
to introduce you all to christy
yamaguchi she is a wife mother olympic
gold medalist children's book author and
founder of the non-profit always dream
kristy yamaguchi's always dream ensures
that children from low-income families
have access to high quality books
welcome christy it's great to have you
here
thank you caroline it's great to join
you thanks for having me
yeah
so the winter olympics just finished
this year is your 30th anniversary since
capturing the gold medal
what is your most cherished memory you
have regarding your olympic experience
and we'd love to hear
a bit more about what the olympics were
like back then
yes so 92 was a while back right
but uh it was a incredible experience i
think uh when you talk to any olympian
one of the
most vivid and fondest memories always
marching in the opening ceremonies and i
think just
being a part of an incredible group of
athletes not just figure skaters but
you know the skiers the speed skaters
the bobsledders biathlons it's just an
incredible pool of talent and it's so
humbling
and i think there's no prouder feeling
than
you know putting on our team usa
uniforms and and marching in together
representing our country so uh so that i
think will always be an incredible
special moment and
you know the games themselves are just
um
you know something that's a lifelong
pursuit and it's it's so amazing uh just
to be there and an honor to represent
but uh you know the competition gets a
little intense
as you can imagine
but uh you know lots of fun too i mean i
knew i was prepared and i was ready for
that moment and
even though my nerves were you know
creeping in and giving me a little bit
of
that scary feeling i kept telling myself
you know go out there do what you're
trained to do and the preparation is
going to
hopefully uh
be is you know something i can rely on
and it and it came through for me so um
i feel very fortunate every day
yeah it clearly did and and i'm sure
there were
many life lessons that you learned as a
figure skater what were some of those
that
carried over into your
work now in raising and teaching kids
uh yeah i mean that's such a great point
and i think it's all about having a
dream right and really going after those
dreams
and uh and really encouraging kids to
use their imaginations and to open up
their minds to what's possible out there
and uh and then you know putting the
time in and working for it so you know
all good stuff to kind of set goals and
you know
encourage uh the kids to like really go
after what they want and and put some
work or or you know effort into it and
you never know what can happen
absolutely it's that combination of the
hard work and the dreams that that yes
clearly have taken this part
so you've written three books and you're
also um
working um with early childhood literacy
how did you
get into that from figure skating and
you you started quite early in your
career as well
yes so uh uh
my organization always stream was
established in 1996
and uh we are all about uh embracing the
hopes and dreams of
uh underserved children and the last 10
years we've really focused our efforts
on the early childhood literacy and
i think really the inspiration behind
that was being a mom becoming a mom
myself i had
uh i still have two daughters but at the
time they were four and six so kind of
at that learn to read age um you know
had an incredible
high interest in books and just you know
reading at home and i think my husband
and i just saw the incredible value that
that had and and the
pure benefits that they received from it
as they were starting to get ready for
school
and um i think you know looking around
in our country and some of the
statistics of you know 60 percent of
low-income families don't have
age-appropriate books in the home and
you know close to
you know 40
of our fourth graders in the united
states are uh
you know reading at or above grade level
i mean those are numbers we really want
to change and i felt like
um that was something i i was really
passionate about and wanted to really
turn our focus on
absolutely and and now you're working
with school districts and and using
technology to help
get those resources into classrooms can
you tell us a little bit more about that
yeah so we have a program called always
reading
and
it's focused on
pre-kindergarten and
kindergarten age students
and we're primarily in title 1 schools
so
where resources are are very much needed
and
provide one-to-one a tablet with e-books
and
so a wide
range of selection of titles and
subjects for the kids to pick from
but we also pair that with family
engagement support
and with that support we reach out to
the families three times a week with
text messages and
there's everything from
uh reading tips and strategies to little
gentle reminders of like hey there's 10
new books
in your library you know why don't you
pick one out and read your child tonight
in some you know and sometimes uh
questions to maybe ask your kids as
they're they're you're reading a book
with them together so
um
you know it's a it's a program that we
really really
love to see the change in behavior of
the families at home that they do set up
a literacy rich environment with their
child and spend that time
engaging with them and and just
understand the importance and the impact
that that will have on their child as
they move uh forward in their education
that's great and i love that you have
implemented these tips
do some of them come from tips that
you've
acquired as a mom as you were teaching
your kids to
read uh definitely i think you know we
do everything we can to get them
interested in books right and sometimes
it's not easy but i think you know
keeping it fun
is uh always a great thing and
you know even if it means just picture
walking a book with your child like
looking at a picture and
asking them oh hey there's dream big
little pig like what color is her dress
or what is she doing is she playing
basketball and you know and it prompts
them to kind of think and
um answer and really get more involved
with what they're reading so
you know keeping it fun was was one
thing for sure
absolutely kids are always you know
playing and learn the best through play
so i love that that playful
approach to learning
um
tell us about the children's books that
you've written
yes no absolutely so um there's three
books one is called dream big little pig
uh there it is poppy the pig
as you can see uh is interested in ice
skating and she tries a few different
things before she finds ice skating and
once she finds ice skating she discovers
she loves it and so this one's all about
persistence and uh you know not giving
up and going after your dreams even
though there's challenges in front of
you
and then i also did a follow-up from
this called it's a big world little pig
and then cara's kindness is about a
caring cat and
she passes kindness forward
and only ask that her friends do the
same thing and
uh you never know the the kindness can
come full circle back to you so
you know each one has a little bit of a
positive message that hopefully kids can
take away and and maybe uh and implement
in their own lives
yeah
and speaking of facing challenges we
have a question from khushi
from youtube
and she was asking how to keep how do
you keep going on in spite of having low
scores or performance i'm assuming
in regards to reading um
you have some
ideas for that yes um
maybe
maybe a parent or maybe a teacher sounds
like um
you know i mean i think it's like
finding something that will
inspire
that child to really pick up books as
much as possible and
um
you know i think it's important to have
uh options of choice because when a
child is able to pick and choose they
take a little bit of ownership of what
they're reading and i think that makes
it a little more fun and it's
you know it might prompt them to read
that book again and again which is
always great um or even maybe inspire
them to find other books in that same
subject so um
you know i think choice in in letting
them pick uh is a big key to getting
them interested and
um and maybe you know finding other fun
ways
to
um you know to get them reading maybe
even
be outside and if something interests
them like they see a truck go by and
they're like wow look at that big truck
and
you can say let's go find some books
about trucks and learn more about them
uh so you know little tricks like that i
think uh are great ways to get a child's
interest in in books even if they don't
realize they're learning something they
are
absolutely especially for the youngest
kids i think
uh the songs and the rhymes have so much
phonemic awareness skills that you can
can build as you're
singing those songs and
playing games too i think with young
young kids so
yeah love that idea of having choice i
think with books you know hopefully now
you know kids can find books that
they're with subject matter interests
that they're interested in that that can
go a long way
um
we have another question from sam lewis
from youtube
how do you press on when your faith is
being tested beyond all you can give and
i i hear him from you know these times
during the pandemic especially with
young children
at home these are challenging times um
yes uh yes
that's a tough one and i think it's
something that uh you know we all face
at some point in our lives and it's uh
you know it's maybe finding ways to dig
deep and see
you know maybe what we do have instead
of
thinking of all the challenges and the
hard things in front of us um
you know taking stock in some of the
positive things that we do have and
letting that
lift you up a little more i know it's
not necessarily going to change your
situation but
uh sometimes it's just
you know a different perspective
mentally can sometimes
uh bring about a little bit of change or
you know inspire change in this in a
different way but
um you know it is tough i think leaning
on people that are close to you and that
you have
a trust in
and i think don't be afraid to reach out
because um
you know there are some
incredibly
you know generous people out there in
their hearts where they definitely want
to um
you know
give whatever advice or
you know tips to to help out
yeah thank you
um we have
another question from
my little dog
yes yes
we're
dog mom here so you must be someone
outside
we are all dog fans here on our team
another question from dia sama from
youtube what inspired you
to be a figure skater
ah yes
so basically
i had
seen an ice skating show when i was
younger and i loved the
music and the performances and the
costumes of course as a little girl
and um i think there was so much about
skating that was magical and
when i begged my mom to take me actually
something that ties in so perfect here
is like she said okay well when you're
six and you learn to read
then i'll take you to the ice rink so
that was big and you know motivation for
me to to get reading and everything and
uh from the first time i tried it at six
years old i just absolutely loved it and
uh kept asking me to go back and um i
think there were the freedom on the ice
and the feeling of movement and
kind of like skiing you know you feel
the wind in your face and your hair and
uh there's just something exhilarating
about that and you know learning to do
the jumps and the different
um
moves on the ice was always a challenge
but
you know obviously incrementally just
great rewards and that feeling of
accomplishment when i was able to learn
something new so
uh so yeah lots of things inspired the
skating
that's fascinating and i love that it
was tied to reading from the beginning
clearly your mom shared the same values
that you do
yes for sure
what were your favorite books at that
age
oh
okay good question
trying to think well i had this one
little
book called um
bear's birthday
and it wasn't by a big publisher i think
it was actually like one of those books
given out at hallmark or something
but i had a little bear that went on an
adventure on his birthday and you can
pull him out of each page and stick them
into the new environment on the on the
consecutive pages so it was
always a lot of fun
um
can you think of other
little bit books um
as a kid that age i mean i remember
you know maybe a little older loving
charlotte's web
and yes if you see a pig connection
there i did have a big thing about pigs
so
um so of course charlotte's was one of
my favorites uh as i was more middle
school age
uh-huh
yeah well you know we've seen and you
wang from youtube asked us you know what
do you think is the reason that little
kids like to read the same book over and
over again
and related how can we get them to
explore different books
oh
you know actually it's a good thing to
read books over and over again and the
repetition is uh so good for kids
you know in that age range and you know
they'll hear the same words over and
over and starting to comprehend
things a little bit more so you know i
definitely encourage reading books over
and over and we actually do that in our
always reading program
um and it you know if if that's what
they want to read as
or have read to them then at least
they're hearing something right
and um but you know i think if you find
another book with a similar
uh character or a subject matter you can
introduce that and say hey this is just
like you know such and such book let's
see if there's like a new adventure in
this that you'd be interested in and um
you know i think no matter what it is if
you can get them you know interested in
books that's that's the that the key
um but yeah don't don't worry about the
repetition it's that's always a good
thing absolutely i'm there with you i
remember the days when our kids were
young and we for parents it seems very
very repetitive i remember reading the
same books over and over night after
night um but in our work we've also
noticed that children they'll read the
same book but they'll be looking at the
pictures and if you ask them questions
they may say something different the
next time
and then sometimes we've seen that
children
start
even pre-reading they will start
reciting the book you know because
they'll remember it um so that's all
you know good and and part of learning
so yes but definitely like like the tips
on
um exploring different books as well
sam lewis from youtube has a question
may i ask how to keep a two-year-old
still
long enough to read to
oh
let's see it's been a long time since my
kids for two
they're 16 and 18 now
um
you know let him sit on your lap or hurt
him or her and
look at the book
you know feel the book and i don't you
know
let them take charge i think sometimes
you know let them turn the page maybe
say hey can you
for example good night moon because that
was one that
our kids wanted to hear over and over
and over and of course find the little
mouse on every page so you know maybe
make it a little bit of a game there
like oh can you find the mouse on this
page and it kind of occupies them i know
two years old is it is maybe a little i
think they would understand that
um
but yeah i think it's
you know
five even five minutes if it you know is
is enough to kind of start that and as
they get older they might
you know you could probably build up to
10 minutes a day and
that even 10 minutes a day is going to
make a huge difference in
um
creating a really strong foundation for
their literacy
habits and skills
and sometimes we can borrow from from
teachers who are so good about setting
up those reading routines in the school
day sometimes at home parents can you
know set aside some time for reading so
after dinner or before bed um children
are growing up expecting that time that
sometimes helps too when they
children generally like the routine
yes they do
yeah um sharon from facebook asked us do
you have a variety of genres you prefer
for your personal reading
ooh um
yeah i kind of bounce all over the map i
mean lately i've kind of been going back
to
some like um
more action and thriller
i like a lot of spy novels and
you know kind of the
like cia kind of
type suspense ones but then
uh
you know i read a couple of great ones
uh over the summer
um
where the crawdads sing i'm not sure if
you guys familiar with that it was
incredible book and uh
so yeah i kind of like to explore
all different things but um i know i
definitely love adventure and uh and
even fantasy like lord of the rings that
whole series is one of my favorite
um
growing up
great
so maybe now going back
back to your past
in
as a kid of
children um in our demographic how was
your what was your training like when
you were first starting out at six to
eight years old
so
you know i mean at six to eight i was
still kind of getting to know skating a
little bit so it was maybe
you know going a couple times a week
after school
or whatever uh and then maybe building
up to a few times a week
so it wasn't uh real uh
you know strenuous training at that
point uh
maybe
you know a little bit older when i was
closer to middle school age then i
started going a little bit before school
so that's when the early morning started
where my
parents were you know my mom would get
up
early take me for an hour two before
school and then sometimes after school
so i think that's you know more 11
12 is when i start to get more serious
and committed to
really focusing in on on more training
and then over the years as you competed
how did you build up the mental
toughness that you needed
um to prepare for you know the
pressure of being at the olympics and
being on a worldwide stage
it i mean it comes gradually right but i
think um my coach was really incredible
christine ness
at
really preparing her students to
mentally be tough in competition
and
you know she was a great technician and
trainer that had us physically prepared
but also
you know wanted us to be mentally tough
as well and so she she was tough on us
in training like she never
let up and uh
you know i i wouldn't say too much tough
love but a little bit and
um you know she she would try to get us
into that feeling and that
uh
atmosphere of uh a little bit of nerves
and practice once in a while especially
when we would perform our
uh practice our routines
just so that
when we felt those nerves in competition
it was you know it wasn't something that
was
new and kind of uh
you know uncomfortable
well
it wasn't comfortable but you know you
knew how to deal with it and you knew
that okay even though i feel a little
shaky i can still go out there and uh
perform
uh okay
and what was it like being one of the
first asian american figure skaters
representing the us
uh well i think i feel more the impact
now than i did at the time you know at
the time i didn't
know that and
um you know i knew that at the very very
top world level there were very few
asian americans
at the time tiffany chin
who
won the bronze world medal and was u.s
national champion in the early 80s was
one of my big uh idols in in role models
so
you know i definitely looked at her and
i felt that connection because she was
also asian american and
california girl like me um
so you know i didn't really feel like oh
you know
i'm trying to blaze a trail here like oh
there's a lot of pressure um i probably
didn't really realize what had happened
until you know
after the olympics and when it was
kind of brought more to my attention
like oh hey you're the first asian
american to
win a gold in uh the winter olympics was
like oh really okay that's cool
um and i think when i saw
[Music]
you know how much it meant to the asian
american community
i think that's when i realized like oh
wow this is um
you know this
this does mean something and
i think it made me reflect a lot more
and be
uh even more appreciative to
you know the history of my my family uh
here in the us and
and really the sacrifices and the trail
that they blazed so that i could really
live that american dream
wonderful well it's just been such an
inspiration to have this conversation
with you
and to hear about all your not only you
know your olympic history but also your
deep work
um with children in early literacy so
thank you so much christy for taking the
time and sharing with our audience and
absolutely
yes thank you caroline it was so great
to talk to you and an honor to talk to
you too and
you know just huge fan of khan academy
kids and uh just love love what you guys
do too to encourage
all of that early education because it's
it's so important
well thank you so much and
if folks want to uh
see this
um just find this
podcast wherever you get your your
podcast and look for
khan academy ed talks and we will see
you next time
thank you
you